ladies and gentlemen Jack Lemmon and
Walter Matthau
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material previously produced or
published are Paul Attanasio for Donnie
Brasco based on the book Donnie Brasco
my undercover life in the Mafia by
Joseph D Pistone with Richard Woodley
Brian Helgeland and Curtis Hanson for LA
Confidential from the novel by James
Ellroy a tongue egoyan for the Sweet
Hereafter
adapted from the novel by Russell banks
Hilary Hankin and David Mamet for wag
the dog from the novel American Hero by
larry beinhart Hossein Amini for the
wings of the dub adapted from the novel
by Henry James
and the Oscar goes to Brian Helgeland
and Curtis Hanson
British accent is written for other
films including the bedroom window brian
helgeland writing credits include
conspiracy theory and the postman this
is their first Academy Award
hey my sons relentlessly play with
action figures at home and I am
constantly left out and that's all going
to end tonight because I'm bringing this
guy home and just for Kansas City
tonight this is a from now I'm going to
be called an Elroy in my house thank you
very much to be handed this by two
actors whom I will always associate with
Billy Wilder makes it all the sweeter
when we acknowledge James Ellroy who
wrote the novel which was our
inspiration and our challenge a
screenplay is just words on paper we had
an extraordinary ensemble of actors in
LA Confidential who took our lines gave
them emotion humor life want to thank
the Academy for this Oscar and I want to
thank the actors of LA Confidential for
making Bryan and me look so good thank
you
now in a few simple declarative
sentences the nominees for the best
original screenplay are Marc Andrus and
James L Brooks for as good as it gets
all Thomas Anderson for Boogie Nights
Woody Allen for deconstructing Harry
Simon Beaufoy for the full monkey
Ben Affleck and Matt Damon for Good Will
Hunting